bonjour nicolas bonjour magali alors on
va parler de cette ce grand entretien
des manuels macro hier alors pour s'
taillé comme un cheveu sur la soupe et
ça vous fait bien sûr réagir bien sûr
vagal hier soir emmanuel macron s'est
offert 30 kg loulou une belle parade
autosatisfaction face à des confrères
pas dit ce truc type pour un sou c'était
une formidable allégorie du journalisme
à plat ventre un mot sur la forme tout
de même rappelez vous qu emmanuel
premier est allé professer la bonne
parole avait le grand blabla lors de la
crise des chez les jeunes devant une
assemblée tri sur le coin du mollet est
gardé par mille crs à chaque déplacement
on a eu droit à six ou sept heures de
monologue ininterrompue manches
retroussées désert de 5 2 mais a paru
c'est peut-être que oui mais c'est au
fait c'était 7 ou 8 on sait plus trop
finalement il était moche retroussé vous
savez est diffusée sans interruption par
les chaînes info mais les choses des
amis ont bien changé et il semblerait
que le on dit waouh de la start-up des
chaînes déteste par dessus tout bon
hormis les chez les jeunes les médias
indépendants les syndicats les corps
intermédiaires les gaulois réfractaires
les antilles passe et bien d'autres
encore et bien emmanuel macron il semble
agir maintenant le direct à la télé
pourquoi je sais que vous me le demandez
et bien parce que l'incontinence verbale
du chef de l'état a été mis en boîte
dimanche après-midi entre la sieste et
le café curieuse t caution président qui
assure annie mélo qui a aimé par dans le
contact le débat et la confrontation des
idées et à cette occasion l'elysée a
sorti deux caméscopes pour nous proposer
hier soir cet entretien réchauffer et
pour rendre le truc un peu plus sexy on
emballe et ça dans la question où va la
france alors je ne sais pas moi je sais
pas vous mais moi quand je tape sur le
gps de mon téléphone portable france
mais le seul trajet qu'on propose c'est
celui qui va à bruxelles mais peut-être
que le gps dg les jeunes des chômeurs
des ouvriers du personnel soignant de
l'hôpital indique plutôt les falaises
d'etretat où la forêt de la désolation
et de ses bucolique marécages sociaux
donc tout va la france eh bien elle va
dans le nu
il lever de boucliers également de
l'opposition est-elle justifiée selon
nicolas bah oui ma grille ont râlé en
bourgogne lorsqu'on est écrasé par une
superpuissance d'ailleurs celle qui fait
la trouille 1 ce matin c'est valérie
pécresse j'étais préparé une petite
soirée saumon olive noix de pécan sur
bfm pour son best of des situations
énigmatique et je vous en cite deux pour
le plaisir je cite les sondages c'est
comme la queue du chien ça va et ça
vient ou une vraie foi la vie est un
puzzle étrange qui un jour s'emboîtant
vous et je vous passe l'histoire du foie
gras du sapin de noël et du tour de
france en même temps chers amis les
républicains ont squatté les antennes
pour quatre débats soporifique du
concours lépine de langue de bois alors
oui l'opposition de marine le pen à jean
luc mélenchon était furax et à juste
titre car emmanuel ou rtf macron a déjà
utilisé un gros crédit de télé et pour
les étourdis je sais qu'il y en a parmi
vous sachez que le 9 décembre dernier
manuel premier nous a fait sa sérénade
sur la présidence de la france à l'union
européenne en janvier prochain pour
faire court on nous a resservi l'asu de
la sacro-sainte souveraineté européenne
qui continue d'être un défi à
l'intelligence et que le président
justifie avait des concepts qui tiennent
sur des post-it alors oui légitimement
les oppositions sont vent debout contre
cette overdose médiatique du président
qui fait comme ça lui va bien depuis le
début de son mandat avec ce sens très
approximatif de la démocratie magali
n'en déplaise à emmanuel macron les
convocations en tout cas de la presse
pour cette petite auto promo ne lui
seront d'aucune utilité s'il veut les
utiliser comme un airbag pour éviter le
crash oui un avis mais que faut-il
retenir sur le fond nicolas on passera
sur le clip d'intro tout match et sur
les nombreuses coupures au montage la
première heure fut formidable magique
grandiose et bouleversante j'ai lu
tellement la larme à l'oeil que jane s y
fait la boîte de moque des kleenex une
heure de confessions intimes de gros
plans des mouvements silence et de
trémolos dans la voix à celles réalisées
c'était super bien réaliser c'est un peu
comme les feux de l'amour ap vous il ya
eu quatre mille cinq cents épisodes mais
c'est quel panache il ya certains
moments à certains moments il ne
manquait plus que nemo vous savez ce le
chien emmanuel decoin de vigie brigitte
sur la moquette une roulade de mac faye
carlito
schumi en arrière-plan et une bande de
100 chamallow du côté du bilan emmanuel
premier a vanté les mérites de sa
révolution tranquille ses victoires ses
triomphes et ce nouveau monde qui est en
train de naître parce que le petit père
du peuple veut bousculer le système mais
apparemment semblant de lui prendre ni
olivier la science alors tous les
français gagnent plus vite moins de mal
et l'économie est repartie et en plus et
en plus emmanuel macron vous aime mieux
chers français hier soir est de vous
envoyer plein de bisous franchement il
faut être muet fait mieux sourds que
d'entendre ça je vous jure a vraiment
rien de nouveau donc sous la voie lactée
jupitérienne de la macro ni gageons
qu'après les voeux du président le
trentaine sans prochain nous aurons
peut-être droit levé du roi comme le
faisait 8 14 pour sa déclaration de
candidature retransmise en direct mais
l'entente du bon vous l'avez compris il
faut se préparer à une nouvelle dose du
rappel du président macro on a mis un
avis de man 2 et pour sa gouverne le
débat de l'entre-deux-tours ne pourra
pas être enregistrée dans le bunker du
conseil de défense trois jours avant
donc il faudra alors penser à
l'hologramme où trouver d'ici là le don
d'ubiquité
mais vu que tous nos chercheurs se sont
tirés l'étranger ça va être coton en
tout cas charge ami pierre dac écrivait
je cite la télévision est fait pour ce
qui n'est en n'ayant rien à dire
tiennent absolument à le faire savoir à
volonter dure un peu d'ailleurs saluer
surtout bisous et et joyeux noël est en
tout cas il y aura une intervention du
chef de l'état avant les voeux c'est
vendredi sur france inter avec des
enfants cette fois ça sera formidable
est magnifique merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci c'était l'édito politique
de la matinale ce matin